i'm taking the f-word on the road
because it's the last week of my
competition to find the f-word's best
local restaurant
on tonight's second semi-final the
pheasant retsina and simply thai
at the pheasant in rural cambridgeshire
i love their passion for their local
produce
and i was massively impressed by the
sheer hard work and dedication of
husband and wife team jay and tafita
check on two covers two
rabbits
and at racine in london i was charmed by
another family this time mother and son
working together to create wonderfully
authentic greek food
as soon as our family business it's been
going on for around 25 years i want
razor to be known as the best restaurant
in the uk
and at simply thai in middlesex i tasted
some of the best thai dishes i've ever
eaten
well
calorie dynamo petraeurapan puts a heart
and soul into running this place almost
single-handedly
she's remarkably talented
i've got to pick the very best
restaurant how by setting them all three
very tough challenges
for the first test i've hired a team of
food experts to work undercover for me
as secret diners
i'm quite excited about this place it's
a trick of the western trade i use all
the time
i spend a fortune on secret diners
coming to all my restaurants it's a
really good way to see how consistent a
restaurant is on a daily basis
hello i've got a table book yeah just
two years yep
i'm sending my secret diners to all
three restaurants who have no idea
they're being filmed
i got a reservation um in the name of
beth i have to find out how the
restaurants perform when they're not in
the spotlight and their guard is down
this should be interesting
whichever restaurant fails to impress me
on this test will be eliminated
first up the pheasant
it's a great british restaurant where
huntsman leave their wellies at the
front door and they're killed around the
back
customers turn up and throw a brace a
pigeon down or some mallard we trade off
we might cook them a duck supper and
that's payment for it really
i hope my secret diner is in for a treat
because i thought the service here was
first rate
could i possibly have the homemade black
pudding please
i've asked trish davis to go undercover
today because she's an experienced food
specialist
don't like waiters when they lean on the
table what wine would you recommend for
me to have with my first clothes please
of course yeah that's the black pudding
um
in comes the owner to the rescue rapidly
the hellfire
yesterday
yeah good
here we go i've asked trish to complain
about the food even if it's perfectly
cooked i'm ever so sorry but my potatoes
are just slightly under cooked
would you prefer math
oh that's really kind of you know i'll
just go with one go with them a bit more
would you prefer mash again coming up
with solutions all the time no
negativity the secret is a great
solution
slow start and then it was brought back
to life with taffeta good
okay had a
cena next up red cena in north london
smells good anyway
someone's been busy cooking that's what
we're all about fantastic
it's run by mother and son minos and
zeta
i'll go with the mitts kebab that sounds
great
they don't have a clue that my secret
diner sam head has booked a table
i've asked sam to chat to the staff to
see how they engage with everyday
customers
oh perfect thank you very much
so sorry
nope
[Music]
he's not very attentive i keep trying to
catch his eye i can't get him he's doing
his best to ignore me
[Music]
i'm actually here because i went around
the greek islands in the summer so it's
a bit of a treat to try and reminisce
ah that's the reason yeah
they're talking about the authenticity
of the greek isles just come back from
the summer holiday and wow he didn't
give a [ __ ] he's off looking out the
window wasn't even engaging with the
customers totally uninterested what a
shame are you cooking um
lovely to see
out comes the chef bless her now you're
having a lovely time thank you
i'm chubby now
i apologize that's how chef should smell
onion guys
how are you really good thank you we're
having a lovely time thank you
yeah thank you
enjoy your cooking
the saving grace there was
zita's welcome little kiss on the cheek
welcome good to see you and i've just
come out of the kitchen and she looks
like she's been busy which is fine
simply thai
so will my final target simply thai and
teddington doing you better
with just nine tables it's a tiny
restaurant run by a tiny chef but betray
has a hugely passionate temperament
[Music]
i feel like i met the female gordon
ramsay from bangkok
where is it
where
this is gonna be fascinating what's the
reception gonna be here this lady scares
me does say if you have a limited amount
of time please let our staff know
my last secret diner beth heald is about
to risk the wrath by the thai culinary
fire brand
because i've asked beth to act as if
she's in a hurry so we've only got about
an hour is that going to be okay
thank you very much
what time do you have
that's patriarch coming out of the
kitchen almost sort of telling the
customers off which we've only got an
hour
we are in we are in a little bit of a
rush but
um
by nine o'clock
and she looks like she just came out of
a kickboxing competition i mean she's
that she's ready for action
the cod balls are still light and fluffy
um
really really tasty what shocked me more
than anything was the i suppose the
aggressive stance
from patria coming up to the customer we
don't do fast food granted but they only
ask him we've got an hour we want to
spend our money in your restaurant
dear idea that's a great shame
so it's time to eliminate one of the
restaurants
[Music]
my decision is based on everything i've
seen and learned so far
including hours of invaluable undercover
down
evidence
no one has any idea i've been spying on
them
but i have told them that one restaurant
is about to be knocked out of the
competition
today is a big day i haven't felt this
nervous since probably when we when uh
tough and i got married i'm excited now
looking at the clock all the time you
know just when the phone gonna ring
we hope that
we will
win again
good afternoon the pheasant hi james
gordon ramsay how are you hello gordon
very well thank you good good good have
you had a good week it all depends on
what you say
yeah
the
the secret of any good restaurant is in
the consistency yep now unknown to you
and taffeta we've had the f-word secret
diners eating at the pheasants
okay
well
as you know
being shortlisted is a great achievement
and you know
i think you guys did phenomenally well
right there's only two are going through
to the semi-final
yeah
[Music]
and the pheasant
yep
it's one of them congratulations james
[Applause]
i'm totally aesthetic you know it's best
the best best news
you know
apart from my daughter's being born it
really is i'm just
you know i can almost cry my big tough
mum
the pheasant didn't put a foot wrong and
quite deservely they now have a chance
to win a place in the final
we are through to the next round
welcome back it's the semi-final of my
best local wretched competition and
three teams are fighting replacing the
final only one will go through
so far in tonight's second semi-final my
best local british greek and thai
restaurants have been put to the test
we've only got about an hour is that
gonna be okay
i sent in a team of secret diners to
investigate the contenders and the
pheasant pass with flying colours
[Music]
they're still in the running
[Music]
but now i have to eliminate one of the
two remaining restaurants
be going out of the competition simply
thai or at cena
i feel quite confident i think
i'm going to win this one as well i'm
exciting now looking at the clock all
the time you know just when the phone
gonna ring
[Music]
good evening simply try
hello now i've had the f words secret
diners
i had the f word secret diners eating in
your establishment zita that food is
amazing the important part in order to
get
100 record is to make sure that you've
got the service to match it
the name of the game is consistency
so
red cena
isn't going through
unfortunately the secret diners felt
that they were ignored by the waiter
feel welcome when they come in for the
first time we have to
learn for our mistake
take care zita thank you
have a nice week thank you
if i say that i'm not disappointed i
will lie i am disappointed but i'm not
going to let myself feel bad because
some these things happen i'm upset that
people came here and they didn't feel
comfortable in my restaurant and you
know that's not good enough
and simply ty
congratulations
the feedback from the f-word secret
diners has been extraordinary so
congratulations pretty well done
and i can't wait to see you in the
semi-final oh thank you
so i've chosen simply tie from
teddington to fight it out with a
pheasant from cambridgeshire
[Music]
to be worthy of a place in the grand
final they have to survive two more
challenges
first i've asked 30 f-word diners to
test the pheasant and simply tie to
breaking point
and i'm going to judge both restaurants
performance more critically than ever
before
we're going to have lunch at the
pheasant
and then dinner at simply thai
your feedback is absolutely pivotal to
helping me make my decision on which two
restaurants go through the actual final
so basically today you're actually my
eyes and ears across that dining room so
be upfront honest vocal and really give
me your opinions in terms of what you
think not just on the food from the
minute you enter that dining room
with the pheasant under intense pressure
i'm going to watch like a hawk front of
house and behind the scenes in the
kitchen
i know this is every russian's worst
nightmare 30 diners all arriving at once
so in terms of the menu we've stuck to
what we do at the pheasant i'm feeling
excited confident yeah we're good to go
i'm going to test the team to the limit
and if jamie's staff support each other
today it should run light clockwork on a
personal note i just want to say really
well done for making it this far two
hours to cook for 30 guests they're not
here just for the food it's everything
the warmth of welcome make sure that
every plate you send jay you're happy
with if you're not happy with don't send
it make this now the service of your
lives
[Music]
so the cartridge
and the hair
straight away i can see the front of
house staff are creating a good first
impression your service is friendly
attentive again and everyone's little
busy bodies running around making sure
that bread butter water and constantly
observing which is always nice
the vibe in the restaurant is really
nice um really cozy and quite a warm
feel to it two covers one halibut one
pork chocolate sponge and a brulee yes
yeah
the first table up now it's it's all
going okay
it's all good all the orders in here all
the orders are in
everyone is done
we've only been here 20 minutes and my
diners are enjoying their starters that
smells amazing lovely big hit
big hit yeah it smells delicious it's
really good
how's the beef excellent beef um
beautiful flavors
the flavours just work really really
well together very happy with my dish
yeah jay's a very controlling chef very
hands-on he's at the sort of central
point on the hot plate and everything
comes up to him so he misses nothing
everything's scrutinized overseen tasted
as well
a good sign
so far so good but i'm worried about
jay's main course
he's cooking hair three ways with hair
wellington lasagna and bray's leg all on
the same plate
you eat it it's [ __ ] hard
it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's a dish which requires very precise
timing and i think jay's misguided to
try and offer this to 30 diners all at
once
these weddings in the shirt they've uh
they've just sat like that and the
juices have made the pastry go all soggy
so they're just rubbish
hair's difficult enough to cook cooking
it three ways that's ambitious
jay's got somewhat backed up in the
kitchen cooking it three ways that's
like putting that noose around your neck
so i just hope he hasn't bitten off too
much that he can actually do and the
brigade can execute because right now
he's in the [ __ ]
[ __ ] one day that [ __ ] matters and
we can't do it [ __ ] properly
[ __ ] rubbish
jay has to start the hair from scratch
we should leave some of my diners
waiting for their lunch
uh this one's 100 better
yeah the pastry is still soft sorry
still crunchy
okay hair sauce
but when it does reach the table the
hair three ways is a resounding success
it's just really really succulent really
really soft didn't even have to cut it
with a knife very tunneling flavors nice
hearty tasty food very nice
but just as i think jay's back on track
there's a problem with the pudding do
you want me to take it away
i'm gonna go and find out what earth
they're up to
just asked if actually the pudding which
is written as um hot chocolate sponge is
i think it's hot chocolate sponge with
orange and unfortunately i don't think
the um
hd really knew that either
jay didn't mention the menu that the
pudding is orange flavored and it's left
a taffeta to deal with his mistake
do you know there's orange in the
pudding
chocolate orange
okay
feeling pissed off service we didn't
work together like i said it was [ __ ]
the wellingtons were crapped as well it
wasn't cooked properly
you know it it just didn't
wasn't it was you know it's not good
enough despite a couple of issues most
of my 30 diners really enjoyed their
lunch you got coffees ordered in your
room every table sorted
and the food was very good indeed but
jay's timing today was in danger of
compromising the entire service
tough challenger yeah 30 guests all
arriving at the same time i thought
you'd cope brilliantly well
walking in
and seeing food like that
the salmon and it looked amazing tasted
fantastic so job well done if i've got
one concern cooking hair jay is a very
difficult thing
trying to cook it three different ways
yeah yeah is you know on the verge of
you know over ambitious this jay taffeta
was a tough challenge today
but well done really well done and i
mean that thank you
i look forward to seeing you the next
challenge bye guys
thank you
overall my diners leave feeling
satisfied with their meal but jay knows
the performers in the kitchen was far
from flawless
disappointed
pissed off
angry
i think jay is being incredibly hard on
himself i have to say i don't think that
it was as bad as he thinks it is he is
just being absolutely meticulous on
every single which of course you should
be but the food came out looking
fantastic i was very pleased to serve it
next stop dinner at a restaurant that
couldn't be more different simply thai
and teddington
57 year old head chef petraea runs this
place almost single-handedly i'm
everything
chef accounting bookkeeping managing
director
cleaner everything
when i first ate here the food was
stunning so i hope petra will serve
exquisite cuisine tonight
hello
how are you
ladies welcome first of all
congratulations thank you really well
done now you know there's only two
restaurants that are going through to
the final so tonight
yes has to be your best ever service two
hours yes two hours starting from now
off you go right off you go out to the
front
now the menu you got all your best
dishes on there yes yes yeah okay you
got the sea bass yes i've got the zebras
then they've got the chicken penang
you've got all the chicken they've got
all the sauce right look at the prawns
it got asparagus okay
but but trey will be under pressure and
i'm worried this could be a test too far
for her tiny restaurant which is now
full to capacity
so you're on your own um i was on my own
but i got in where's my girl who's in
the kitchen with you
bonnie has she explained in the dishes
to you yes what are the starters is that
to him no not you
[Music]
yeah you're doing this on purpose aren't
you to give me an ulcer pretty nervous
for petraeus i mean she's got no help in
there she's on her own
two courses each 30 days that's 60
dishes in two hours cooking on your own
how's he gonna cope with this one i
don't know
[Music]
the waitresses don't know how to handle
my 30 diners
and immediately everything's chaotic
you take all the food no two person take
the drink so it's been 10 minutes now
not one order in the kitchen
what's going on outside
[Music]
we've been here for a quarter of an hour
and the kitchen's only just kicked into
action
one quail one spring rolls now please
laura watch your hands come here
as the orders come in all at once laura
the kitchen porter is commandeered as
sous chef
one spring rolls one smoke clothes
spring rolls cycle beach open in it
petraeus spring rolls are by far the
most popular choice of starter enjoy
one more spring roll now please i got
another three spring rolls left after
this one only three spring rolls left
[Music]
table
three table three
half an hour gone
are you served four tables hold on a
minute
look come here somebody didn't listen to
me i haven't got any more i don't have
enough spring rolls i told you i don't
have spring rolls for table two and
table four just go and apologize to them
ask them to something else now now
they're selling food they haven't gone
she's running out of spring rolls they
told them that 15 minutes ago but no
one's listening to her
and the food's coming out it looks
immaculate and the customers are happy
with the food but it's about to go tits
up we waited quite a long time for our
starters to come out and when it came
it's amazing really really good food so
we can't really halt the food at all
it's just
i think it's the actual volume of people
arriving at once maybe putting a bit too
much pressure on the kitchen table seven
i apologize
sorry
we are late
turn up no
put it here leave it there
in the chaos dishes are being sent out
before they're even finished
where is the front
where young
[ __ ]
the plan is not finished yet excuse me
yeah it's not ready yet
laura don't do it again okay
i feel much safer on the [ __ ] bus
than i do in there um so sad we're
halfway through an hour to go and she's
only got two main courses out so she has
to keep it together she can't talk she's
getting frustrated and she's getting
flustered and it's such a shame because
when the food arrives
the diners love it
so far the service is nothing short of
disastrous but at least petraeus food is
amazing
it looks fantastic simply thai this has
gone fancy thai no it's simple
table one
that's more complex than my food
[Music]
oh my god that's delicious that's good
you seem to have got some rhythm going
on now main courses are flying out table
two concentrate don't make mistake
please please table two
petraeus finally seems to be settling
down and there's some semblance of order
i had the chicken penang for the main
course i thought it was absolutely
fantastic it's a shame about the weight
but the food and the flavors for me was
absolutely delicious if she can sort out
the front of house service and maybe get
somebody else in the kitchen and i think
this restroom will definitely go places
right
well done you finished and you finished
with
just over five minutes to go five
minutes ago oh that's brilliant well
done
i thought i'm gonna collapse in the
middle of the night no no we're not
gonna make it i didn't i said at one
point i said in my mind you know in my
head no we're not going to make it we're
not going to make it we're not going to
make it it's a really good job and i'm
very proud
thank you very much i'm really proud
well done thank you
i've done
at the top of my ability today and um
you know and i've got through it the big
difference across all the semi-finals is
that every other restaurant has cooked
for 30 customers
this is fully booked for her they've all
got 60 70 80 90 seats she never does 30
kills so not only has she managed to do
30 covers within 2 hours
she's done it single-handedly
amazing
thank you for supporting me
[Music]
next my two contenders will face the
ultimate challenge cooking at my
three-star flagship restaurant
the biggest test is still in front of
them who's going through the final right
now i haven't got a clue welcome back to
the f-word simply thai and the pheasant
are fighting out for a place in the
final
tonight two semi-finalists have already
faced two daunting tests
under pressure in their own restaurants
i'm seeing their true colours
at the pheasant jay is a
perfectionist check on two covers two
rabbit
he's passionate about game and awful and
obsessed with fresh local produce
creating dishes from the same day's kill
i love offal it doesn't have to cost a
fortune to be good food and you know
we're finding customers do love it but
i've also seen jay dejected
[ __ ] one day that [ __ ] matters and
we can't do it [ __ ] properly
a simple setback can knock his
confidence and affect his performance
service we didn't work together like i
said it was [ __ ] the wellingtons were
crap as well it wasn't cooked properly
you know
it just didn't
wasn't it was you know it's not good
enough
i want to see jay bounce back with a bit
more vigor when things go wrong
[Music]
at simply thai patriaripan is one of the
most dedicated chefs i've ever met
simply thai no that's accomplished thai
cooking um
yeah i mean a real thoroughbred i mean
my god that woman's passion her absolute
commitment to a tiny restaurant is
remarkable table three please table
three
but petraeus fierce independence worries
me even the greatest cooks need support
from their staff
bonnie has she explained in the dishes
to you yes what are the starters oh dear
uh patria
you're doing this on purpose aren't you
to give me an ulcer
and if petraeus gonna make it into the
grand final she needs to work with the
team not just operate single-handedly
now both restaurants face the ultimate
challenge here at my own flagship
restaurant royal hospital road in london
[Music]
jane petraeu must create and serve
exquisite cuisine worthy of a place on
the menu at my three mission style
restaurant
they're cooking one dish the most
important dish of their entire lives
and with that one dish they've got one
final chance to prove themselves
i'm sure i'm not going to ever have
three stars so given the opportunity
here to cook it's going to be brilliant
i'm really looking forward to
just want to get started
to know that golden led allowed me to
cook in his kitchen
i feel very honoured and very nervous at
the moment getting very excited as well
[Music]
i've worked for over 10 years to build
royal hospital road's reputation and
tonight i'm putting it on the line
and i've invited some distinguished
guests including jason atherton who was
awarded a michigan star within a year of
opening maze
i know how tough he is i've worked for
10 years you don't get going around to
semi-final unless you're a damp cup so
credit to them both right
first of all welcome really good to see
you
now this is where it really seriously
matters okay 10 years i've had this
place yeah i had to rent for five years
in order to save my pennies to buy each
and every brick
it's been a dream come true this but
it's the first time in ten years i've
ever handed my ration to any other chef
this is it the final hurdle
make this the best dish of your cooking
career one of you is going through the
final really good luck yeah off you go
the teams are working in one of the most
well-equipped kitchens in britain with
the finest ingredients money can buy
i've challenged both chefs to create one
dish using the best quality cornish beef
which i've provided
it's been matured on the bone for a
month and the meat is succulent with a
beautiful even marbling
okay jay first take it in four cups away
table one four fill it of beef the
pheasant yeah excellent thank you nice
loud call thank you
second table in patria yes chef four
comes away table four four b penang
yes chef so eight
for his dish tonight jay has pushed the
boundaries yet again
he's serving beef fill it with veal
sweet breads and bone marrow bon bons
leave a hole
yeah like that
a little bit less spinach
it's an incredibly daring choice because
it's a very rich combination of flavours
and offal isn't to everyone's taste
jay rolls these fillets of beef into
cylinders and base them with butter
until they're pink in the middle
jay coats the bone marrow bon bons in
flour egg and breadcrumbs and deep fries
them
he soated the veal sweet breads in
butter for five minutes
and then jay serves the dish with
parsnip puree fondant potatoes and a
rich red wine borderlay sauce
three complex elements on a plate can
get you into three times the trouble
if jay loses his concentration or
confidence for even a minute he'll ruin
the meal
only one of us are going through to the
final
today um
you know we want that to be the pheasant
i want it liam wants it to be you know
we're going to do the best we can you
know we want to win you're using the
phillips a little bit of phillip yeah
yep um
sweet breads you just like blanched this
sweet breads we've yeah blanched these
take off the membrane taking off the
membrane now because it's horrible when
you've you pan fry it then they'll be
nice and crispy what the uh panko
breadcrumbs are we're making a um
like a bone marrow bonbon so we're just
getting the bone marrow just shaping it
to a little ball and then we're just
going to fly and then sit on top of the
okay good excellent
the pheasant dish is quite complex
very very rich beef philip
veal sweet breads
bon bons made out of bone marrow uh yeah
this could go completely tits up if he's
not careful
[Music]
service please quit double one please
let's go
[Music]
i am so chuffed that we have got to the
semi-finals i feel like you know it's
anyone's game from here so we could win
i love the
presentation i love the palm fondant the
cleverness in doing the bone marrow
bonbon i thought that was inspired um i
also thought that it wasn't a dish you
ever got bored of you know sometimes you
eat something and you get a third of the
way through anything where am i going to
go now this one was a whole sort of map
of excitement
in stark contrast with jay's earthy
flavors petraeus has chosen a dish with
a complex combination of sweet spicy
salty and sour taste
i would love to win because we are quite
close now
i would love to be in the final it would
mean
a lot to me
this is a traditional thai panang beef
curry with authentic thai sun-in-law
eggs cucumber and pomelo fruit salad
with lime and coriander dressing
petraeus seals the thinly sliced sirloin
steak in oil she drains it and adds it
to warm coconut milk
she makes the traditional panang curry
paste in advance to allow the herbs and
spices to infuse
she fries in sunflower oil until
fragrant and then adds coconut milk and
the beef
petraeus serves the curry with a quail
egg salad and coconut rice
there are so many flavors here the spicy
curry paste and the sweet coconut the
sour lime and the salty fish sauce
patria needs to balance them out with
immaculate precision or the dish just
won't work
now just tell me about the dish very
very quickly i'm going to do the beef
penang and use the sirloin beef yeah
yeah put some fat in there as well yeah
yeah a little bit it's got a little bit
of texture and that's a curry paste that
curry paste yeah do you think this dish
is good enough to beat the pheasants yes
of course it's curry dish it's
much more um stronger flavors and a much
more interesting dish right have you
heard of the pheasants
and yes or no i love freshly no not
pheasant the bird pheasant the
restaurant
pudding
that isn't the restroom i'm bending down
you're bending down low it's harder
to come down
we'll be down on the bench if i bend
down as a torture not for you to bend
down even more standing up
jesus
are you confident with the recipe yes
yes i am sir okay good yeah i've worked
over the last 22 years to get what i
have today in this industry all of a
sudden um i allow a mad thai lady to run
around in my kitchen
i thought she'd be a little bit
intimidated coming here to be honest but
no this is not a lady that's been
cooking like this for the last you know
eight to ten years she's been like this
the last 35 to 40 years and for her it's
all about the food the love and the
passion she puts into the dish patra
yeah chef you have to clean around the
side of the bowl yeah
make sure that you [ __ ] sake
you have to get a little bit more
finesse a little bit yeah
so i'm not gonna send those two until
the two are ready yeah
why does nobody take that because i want
to wait till all the four dishes are
completed yes
yes yes chef thank you service please
you said the rest is coming
this is very very hot it's delicious
very hot the combination of the beef pan
and the rice is quite nice but just
slightly strong
it has some exciting speed for my taste
but overall i think it's very good quite
sweet but uh you know absolutely full of
flavor exactly i was expecting rice
cooked perfection i think patria has
what it takes to win this competition
yes because she's very very determined
she she's absolutely crazy about her
restaurant and
if somebody can win that then it is
going to be her
if petraeus is going to be my winner
tonight i wanted to start communicating
with me and a sous chef nong
no
full salad
not 10 12 14 just four yes
petraeus dish comes with a salad which
needs to be served alongside the curry
it's only four salad not eight yeah so
don't don't do no she
i've told her to do
just the egg chef because we got four
already because it takes time
no
i only need four salad not eight yeah
okay it's only four portions away you're
not yeah only four yeah only four two
four six eight ten twelve there's only
four
only four
only four yeah sure
only four
canal honestly
i mean she just relaxes a little bit and
opens up and at least talks to nong
blank me i'm fine but at least talk to
your sous chef you know it's like we're
back yeah in teddington again in the
sort of nut house uh unbelievable
oh
jay was overcooked that beef
it's not overcooked it's just smaller
than the others so consistency jay i'm
watching everything you know that yeah
everything yeah start to finish chef
when i first met jay
you know laid back rustic cooking from
the garden and all of a sudden bang he's
he started to smell success and he's
he's raised his game now which is good
to see and they work like a team
and they talk to each other and they've
they've got each other's back
[Music]
nice
don't think that needs to come down
anymore
here we are
[Music]
we've got such important customers there
and we're sending [ __ ] all cake down the
side of the [ __ ] you're done
sorry but if you take a little bit more
time putting it into the bowl and not so
messy yeah we don't have to spend so
long cleaning it yeah because i haven't
got the right spoon chef because you
haven't got the right spoon everything
is always a problem what kind of spoon
do you need it is smaller
trista give me a smaller spoon please
yeah
the dish tastes delicious it's authentic
and it's just it's done with love and
care don't throw it out like it's on a
conveyor belt don't complain about my
ladle your spoon too big [ __ ] off you
know just put it in there with a little
bit more time and slow down a little bit
hold on for the beef please uh it's
starting to play in one minute sure yeah
good don't slice it too legi otherwise
it's gonna go dry out there
where's the last one where's the last
one come in chef
serves nice and gently last table table
six well done
braxton switching i'm done now well done
it's all done now
service please last time we had table
for you go please
table four one on j one on lamb thank
you well done
well done well done
so service is over and it's time to
discover the truth of my distinguished
guests
in terms of the
dish cooked from the pheasant
how was that i loved it absolutely loved
it yep it's not something i perhaps
normally choose off a menu but it was
just so nice the sweet breads in
particular were fantastic yeah there's
so many different flavors in there all
very distinct but together superb yeah
the boys have done me very proud i'm
really pleased with it it tastes
gorgeous
the presentation was fantastic and i
don't think it's out of place in a
three-star michelin restaurant
was that authentic
beef banana i've eaten in a lot of
fantastic type restaurants and that for
me was as good as as good as it gets
curry wise it was just a shame just like
the touch of sweetness just lost that
bit of authenticity but in general
that's great i preferred to thai dish
today absolutely the flavors were
amazing it was just the right heat for
me
the salad the lime and coriander coming
through it was very very fresh and it
just brought out the ingredients yeah
it's went well yeah i i i'm happy with
the food that i cooked i'm happy with
the side dishes i'm happy with the rice
i'm happy with the presentation i think
it went really well i think it went yeah
no really good um happy with everything
you know um i didn't get in the mood
um
all smiles now i'm not nearly crying
um
so yeah no i think it was really good
yeah good service
[Music]
only one russian can go through to my
grand final and tonight who stays and
who goes
is my decision
it would be disappointing you know to to
get out of this
stage not to go into the final it would
be very very disappointed because um i
you know i cook my heart i put
everything in you know in into this
competition i think we have done enough
to you know i go away going that dish
was good
authentic
thai curry done
brilliantly against a a british flair
with an amazing
level of control and a very talented
chef right now
honestly
it's too close to call
welcome back to royal hospital road
i'm about to choose one restaurant to go
through to the grand final of my
competition to crown the f word's best
local restaurant
will it be the pheasant from
cambridgeshire or simply thai from
teddington
in very different ways they are both
exceptional restaurants
before i make my choice i'm going to
taste the dishes cooked here tonight by
jay and patria
beef plane
simply thai
authentic
got slightly nervous when she was
putting all that sugar
into the pan
is it too sweet
my god is absolutely phenomenal
a proper authentic thai curry
i mean it's sweet instantly then you've
got the heat with the chilies
but it's instantly cooled down with that
wonderful vibrant cucumber salad
incredible
i mean really incredible
she's
she's a freak of nature
that's the most bizarre thing i mean
i've come across amazing thai chefs in
my time but this woman not only driving
around the bend but she is an amazing
talented chef
the pheasant's
fillet of beef sweet bread bon bon a
bone marrow and a fondant potato that is
accomplished unique cooking at its very
best
all together does it work
hmm
my god
that's amazing pasta puree wonderful
beef delicious
spinach bone marrow
that's a little bit gimmicking i didn't
think jay would be into gimmicks however
it does work
so it's the moment of truth
two outstanding restaurants but only one
can win a place in the grand final
okay
first of all well done
both restaurants absolutely brilliant
the feedback has been extraordinary
this has been the toughest
semi-final so far
simply time
brilliant again
patria in the corner slicing the sirloin
ignoring everything i'm saying and just
in the food
what strikes me
about the way you cook
is that you cook from the heart
i thought the dish was stunning it was
authentic i closed my eyes and i ate
that dish and i felt that i was back in
thailand
if i had one criticism it was a little
bit too sweet
the pheasants tonight's performance was
much different than i expected i thought
you were going to play safe
but jay you came out your comfort zone
brilliant absolutely brilliant edgy
daring for me
that was you showing off tonight the
filler beef yes it's the rolls-royce cut
so
it didn't need much work but it needed
accurate cooking the fondant not easy to
get crispy and delicious
and then
the bon bon absolutely delicious
it was a foodie heaven
done with charm but flair
one piece of criticism is the fact that
the sweetbread
was slightly undercooked in the center
i'm looking for one restaurant to go
into the final and it's been a real
tough decision
based
on everything i've seen
the restaurant going through to the
final
is the pheasant
congratulations
absolutely brilliant
[Music]
i am so proud of both of you i feel
absolutely
you madam across this search you're one
of the best chefs that i've found thank
you
really well done come here
really well done
to come this far and um i couldn't get
to the final um a little bit
disappointed but i i prepare a little
bit you know we may not get it
very happy probably you know i don't
give much weight but i am really really
happy
both freshmen produced food worthy of
royal hostel row tonight but ultimately
i was in awe of jay's ambition
he was prepared to take a huge risk and
it paid off thank you very much
absolutely brilliant yeah done with
great flair today the pheasant reached
new culinary heights if anyone tells me
again that this is a little pub in the
middle of nowhere there's cooking
playing simple food
no tonight you've proved everybody wrong
really well done
they deserve to be in the final
now make it yours
well done
[Applause]
so the pheasant from cambridgeshire is
up against la sam from birmingham in the
grand final
both will cook meat provided by janet's
farm in yorkshire and i decide who
should be crowned the f word's best
local restaurant
jay's gone for beef three ways now let's
say less is more that smells delicious
tonight you know that
i could lift that now
and run down to raw hostel road